things got tough in this I should don't
want pretty mode on them
no I wasn't uh I was in the hospital
watching a game like this couldn't watch
it for real I was so scared at the end
yeah I went to turn it up
I mean we do these we do these drills in
practice
I mean look what happened it happens in
the game and we go down and do what we
we're supposed to do
that's crazy I already knew if he was
going to score this job when I was
watching it was like well we got a
two-point play and this is nothing but
coach prom situation so I know we're
gonna make the best decision get down
get out of bounds get the ball back to
the ref Tempo help us out a lot because
that's what happened in this moment
it's perfect
everything was one that's playing man
it's God's plan
you know exactly what he was doing when
he helped us all with this
touchdown Jimmy
that's what we're supposed to do
Tempo play helped us out
tell me
98 98 yards
two minute drill and push property
through those situations so much and
fall camping so much during the week
it's like it just come natural to us now
that we already know what's going on
so we don't shake up in those pressure
moments We rise and impression moments
and we like to be we like the pressure
on this because we get to show everybody
what we're about and that post game of
interview From Shadows cold cold talking
about birdie mode
what was your message to your teammates
when you guys took over the ball of the
two
got the two our last thing was birdie
mode that's it simple Brady mobile
Freddy mode that's it you left too much
time out there
he's been a mentor of yours
yeah of course yeah we talked we talk
after every game I'm sure he's gonna
text me in a second but that's all I was
thinking it's Brady mode and he could do
it I know I could do it and you know we
just alike what was your message
yeah man that's how I felt when we
played TCU when they left us too much
Tom went down and scrape
is too much time
okay then the ball human did his thing
scored now we stopped him on defense I
was like yeah they messed up and they
left us too much time can't leave us too
much time we're gonna find a way every
time and get out of that and
get the win
monkey came in glitch that was that was
good he came in a clutch
I was happy
oh my god did you see that game
time wow
he's decided for us man he came out as
y'all know he came out and fall Camp
gave us a few words
I see why he's so proud man he's been
with us
he never doubted us we knew we was gonna
have a good team and
so it's about man people that was around
before then
it's like